ich auf jeden fall jeden moment tot bin
alter das man sie dann wenn ich sicher
wäre hallo meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
hier auf meinem kanal und zwar spielen
wir halten sie ich bin eine workbench
aber ich denke ich werde einfach so ein
bisschen rumlaufen und zwar möchte ich
müssen was erzählen
ich glaube ich habe in einer runde mal
fünf minuten zeit was zu erzählen
deswegen mehr länger brauche ich auch
gar nicht und zwar erstmal ihr denkt
euch wahrscheinlich eia heute dienstag
normalerweise legt der kontrakt daher
ein video am tag weil er mehr nicht
schafft wegen uni und anderen sachen die
da noch machen muss
deswegen erwarten wir halt auch noch ein
video und wenn ihr jetzt seht ihr dieses
eine video was heute kam ist eine runde
einzieht denkt ihr euch wahrscheinlich
erstmal schluss mit dem pci wir haben
minecraft hacks erwartet und das sieht
glaube ich jeder wenn auf main kanal
geht die minecraft ist einfach die serie
die bei mir so am meisten mal verlangen
wir die am meisten geschaut wird und so
sieht man ja selber an den klicks in
allen möglichen auch an den bewertungen
dass das auf jeden fall hat gefeiert
wird und ich möchte davon natürlich auch
noch mehr hochladen aber es gibt zwei
dinge über die ich in diesem video reden
möchte und zwar erstens ich hab neues
equipment und 2 ich hab neues equipment
also dass ich habe zweimal neues
equipment gekauft und zwar die erste
sache erstmal ich habe ja geschrieben
ihre freunde ich habe hier ein problem
mit meinem mikrofon
das habe ich gestern gepostet
beziehungsweise was nicht am mikrofon
sondern blickt alles rumprobiert ich hab
ich's lr kabel von dem rüde also das was
ich habe steht dann in der beschreibung
ich habe xlr kabel von rode in mein
normales mischpult gepackt dann noch mal
in den kompressor dann noch mal daran
dann versucht über klinke direkt in den
pc reinzugehen über usb über einen q 802
behringer usb mischpult obwohl ich das
10x 1002 ganz viele sachen habe ich
einfach probiert mit phantomspeisung und
alles mögliche alle möglichen knöpfchen
gedrückt alles gemacht und es hat nichts
geholfen
der kompressor ist wohl irgendwie
einfach kaputt gegangen also ich hatte
ja das sm pro t b 202 das ist auch schon
2005 produziert worden
es ist einfach zehn jahre
heldt ist jetzt schon 2015 das ist ja so
krass irgendwie immer wenn ich halten
zig spiele und liegen wie geraten
schwert bekomme denke ich immer ich bin
direkt so sicher und meine hier die
mitte laufen zu müssen aber ich laufe
einfach auch ein bisschen her also dass
die erste sache dass ich da auf jeden
fall probleme hatte und immer noch zu
dieser erste sache ich hab's gelöst und
zwar habe ich mit vielen leuten
geschrieben unter anderem mit freaks lp
in new york mit real life freuen die
davon ahnung haben mit leuten die
teilweise mit den ich nie kontakt hatte
die haben wir dazu hilfestellungen geben
bei youtube also unter anderem leute von
euch und ich muss echt sagen das ist
richtig richtig cool einfach dass weder
als community zusammen halten dass er
sagte ja und nein
du musst weiter videos machen hier
einige haben mir geschrieben die haben
sich extra darüber informiert nur um mir
eine antwort geben zu können
und das finde ich einfach schon mega
geil von euch aber mir konnte
letztendlich keiner von euch helfen
sondern das teilweise einfach wirklich
kaputt und ich musste wirklich einfach
ein neues kaufen weil ich hab den
entwickler auf all den entwickler den
hersteller auch angeschrieben
das ding da der led indikator bei einem
kompressor leuchtet und diesel pkw
produzieren das ding der zwei jahren
nicht mehr
keine ahnung die native weiterhelfen
wenn dass der support schon sagt dann
ist es für mich so ein klarer fall die
wissen das ding ist fehlerhaft und
wollen es nicht zugeben deswegen ich wer
gedacht komm ich investiert 150 euro
kaufen wir neues hat mir jetzt neues
kompressor mischpult gekauft habe ich
jetzt wahrscheinlich ich hoffe es ich
habs jetzt in der beschreibung
korrigiert dass ich jetzt neues ab so
hat mir das freaks lp empfohlen der
meteor das ist eigentlich ans träsch
macht das mag an ihm kann er mir bei den
einstellungen helfen er ist jetzt halt
schon offline weil es ist gerade morgen
ist wieder uni und das ist gerade halb
eins also ich hoffe dass ich in zukunft
auch immer noch uni und youtube unter
einen hut kriege aber es ist halt gerade
halb eins es halt nicht mehr online und
kann gerade nicht bei den einstellungen
helfen
aber was ich auf jeden fall sagen muss
ich hoffe dass es für euch erstmal so
für die nächsten drei vier videos so mit
der qualität reicht ich meine vielleicht
über treffe ich mich ja jetzt auch schon
in der letzten quali tät in der anderen
qualität ich weiß es noch nicht genau
weil ich mir noch nicht angehört habe
ich habe erst mal die einstellungen so
vorgenommen wie ich das auf jeden fall
auch beim alten kompressor hatte und ihr
könnt mir einfach mal die kommentare
schreiben wir die qualität findet
das ist die sache numero eins die lösung
eines problems auf dieses kompressor
problem die lösung war einfach dass ich
mir neuen kompressor kaufe und da lag
halt einfach dran
viele haben ja auch geschrieben elia
oder npcs kaputt teoman das liegt an
apple so alle möglichen sachen so
richtig bescheuert einfach da denk ich
mir einfach nur so aim vielleicht
wollten die leute auch nur helfen also
ich möchte denn niemanden irgendwie was
unterstellen
es gibt halt immer nur noch ein sieg er
steht einfach hier wollen wir den mal
helfen das erfolgserlebnis hat der sfk
glaube ich dass afghanistan nie
irgendwie rumgelaufen oder irgendwie so
es steht ja immer noch drin niveau ist
in der ich möchte dass du mich mal tötet
damit ein erfolgserlebnis hat der ist
einfach ganz alaska und jeder gewinnt
das so langweilig das ist auf jeden fall
die erste sache die ich ansprechen
wollte wird ein recht kurzes video denke
ich und das problem ist jetzt auf jeden
fall gelöst da braucht ihr auf jeden
fall keiner verkackt alter egal das ist
nur in game punkte wenn jetzt jeder sagt
drehbücher wenn ich das spiel hätte
gewinnen wollen hätte ich mich auch
irgendwie schiff setzen können und
chillen können aber ich wollte ein
bisschen rumlaufen
die zweite sache die ich ansprechen
wollte war neuer pc und zwar habe ich ja
schon manchmal gesagt ich kaufe mir den
neuen imac 5 kam habe ich jetzt auch
getan und ich muss sagen es ist so
bombastisch geil damit zu arbeiten
einfach also ich mache ja sehr sehr viel
für die uni so an
irgendwelche sachen die ich mache und
ich weiß nicht was ich dass ich da sagen
kann aber diese ganze qualität dieser
dieser schrift und so ich glaube ich
muss da nicht zu sagen die meisten
werden eher sagen hey du scheiße aber
ich weiß nicht ich spiele hier darauf
jetzt auch grad minecraft und ich weiß
nicht also ich hab natürlich jetzt den
flaps 60 fps ich weiß nicht ob es für
euch jetzt ebenso flüssig aussieht oder
nicht aber für mich ist es auf jeden
fall mega flüssig und es läuft alles
mega gut ich wollte zu sagen ich habe
jetzt diesen neuen pc ich habe jetzt
auch hingekriegt alles endlich mal
anzuschließen also ich habe ihn schon
seit zwei wochen
aber ich habe jetzt endlich mal alles
angeschlossen weil also nicht vorher
muss ich ja noch diese ganzen programme
und mit premiere es halt auch so eine
sache mit dieser creative cloud mit
diesem ich hab diesen studenten
tarifgehalt gebucht ist er halt da
irgendwie 25 euro monat habe ich zugriff
auf alle adobe programme und das habe
ich auf jeden fall lange gebraucht um
das da erstmal zu aktivieren weil die
dachten hey das ist ein anderer pc das
bist nicht du bist nicht mehr student du
bezahlst die 36 eur 7 80 oder wie das
dann ist ich habe das nicht eingesehen
ich wickle angesagt
ich bin die gleiche person ich hab nur
neuen pc und das muss ihnen erstmal
klären und zwei transporter jedenfalls
hat jetzt alles nicht im bücherregal
es hat jetzt alles geklappt ich bin
zufrieden mit diesem pcs läuft alles
bestens also ich weiss nicht wenn
irgendwas ruckeln sollte liegt auf jeden
fall am main greift aber es läuft okay
ich hab jetzt auch gerade halten ob die
feinen drin oder irgendwie watt also
nichts was da irgendwie die fps
stabilisiert oder so
und nebenbei lebend grad noch ein
programm runter aber ich weiß ich bin
zufrieden damit mit dem pc und wird
damit dann halt in zukunft meine videos
aufnehmen
das sind erstmal die zwei sachen die ich
zum equipment sagen sollte wollte also
dass ich mir ich bin heute morgen in so
einem musikladen gefahren und hab mir
halt da einfach so ein neues dinge alle
bücherregale chillen einfach ihr mann
können wir nicht zusammen rein oder geht
das nicht hin wenn das location angeht
hier drauf aber dann ist unter der unter
mir total safe einfach mal hier sind
hier sind jetzt so viele bücherregale
commerce 11 ich bin ein sondern auch
noch mal eins nach vorne wir schon
einmal irgendwo über bücher regale
ich wollte auf jeden fall nur das video
machen und ganz kurz bescheid sagen
freunde
ich kann auf jeden fall erstmal mit
einer note notlösung jetzt videos machen
also wie wird das equipment so
beibehalten aber die einstellungen zur
zeit sind eine notlösung einfach nur
dass hier überhaupt tun habt ich hoffe
es ist in ordnung mit dem ton das
wichtige war mir halt dass ich auf jeden
fall jeden moment tot bin
was macht sie dann wenn ich sie gavel
weiß nicht ich laufe einfach mal daher
kommen wir träumen jetzt mal die
siegerin hier so ein bisschen laufen der
hinterher
oder es liegt einfach so auf
es ist ja nicht mehr normal wie das auf
hifi anlagen ist oder steht inhalt
gerade einfach nur um kann natürlich
auch sein dass sie einfach nur rumsteht
die steht halt wirklich nur einfach um
es mit drittem vorn jeder kommando und
es auch noch jemand dies ist auch ein
anderer blog gehe ich mal hierhin hier
geht nicht erhebend lauf amboss lauf
lauf hey das ist halt echt ne dieses
sieger hier sind unter aller kanone war
dass man als das waren halt eigentlich
wird die beiden sachen oder dich reden
wollte dass sich halt jetzt neues mir
einfach mal ein kompressor geholt habe
ich jetzt auch keinen bock hatte mich da
einfach hinter zu schnallen und bei
denen in kontakt
dort anzurufen und dann auf englisch mit
den zulagen und auf englisch
man kann sich halt auch englisch
verständigen aber auf englisch sein
problem nahe zu bringen ohne dass die
komplett denken wenn ich dann so sagt
jakob prezer micro frau und mischt die
denken sich einfach nur danke was willst
du von uns und so da kann man halt sein
problem war echt schlecht rüber bringen
allerdings immer noch hinter mir da wird
einfach in gnadenloser kampf in diesem
forum
jedenfalls habe ich mir dann gedacht ok
kommen cops einfach neues mischpult
vergessen hab ich einfach informiert und
mir weitergeholfen da bin ich den leuten
sehr dankbar
das ist damals und die sache nummer 2
wie ich schon gesagt der neue pcs am
still
das heißt flüssig flüssig freunde all of
you can say but it seven hundred fps und
ich weiß dass das auge nur 60 wahrnimmt
aber es ist auf jeden fall flüssig und
ich hoffe dass damit jetzt ein bisschen
mehr im pvp gewappnet bin und sonst
war's das auch eigentlich
ich wollte heute eigentlich noch effects
aufnehmen an alle die sich jetzt denken
hey mann
bald ist er dienstag holte konya
freiheits man wo bleiben die oh ja es
ist halt einfach wirklich jetzt 20 vor
1 ich habe morgen um 8 uhr auf jeden
fall uni dann muss ich auf jeden fall
früh aufstehen und deswegen wenn ich es
oft facts mache da bin ich halt immer
eine stunde erst mal am facts raussuchen
und das wollte ich mir jetzt ehrlich
gesagt nicht nicht zumuten weil ich habe
diese nacht vier stunden geschlafen weil
ich noch was für die uni machen musste
und auch noch wegen dem probleme mit dem
kompressor gespielt und alles mögliche
noch machen musste deswegen möchte ich
das einfach meinen körper nicht zumuten
das jetzt noch mal so wenig schlaf
bekommt obwohl ich bekomme einfach jetzt
auch wenn ich jetzt nach dem video
direkt ins bett gehen würde
sechseinhalb stunden schlaf will ich
dann bekommen aber warte ich dir einfach
mal in diesem bücher raum wo waren denn
da waren auf jeden fall so mega viele
haider ich hab halt nur noch das wäre
nicht ich hab nur noch 77 sekunden da
links dass die sehr stark nach dem
bücher rollen oder nicht nein möchte nur
dann ist hier vielleicht nie das auch
nicht app ist denn dieser bücher ronaldo
hier ist diese nähe ist er nicht er ist
in dieser bücher raum hp sagen ja ich
wollte jetzt einfach nicht noch zwei
stunden an einen affekt folge sitzen und
danach dann einfach nahezu gar nicht
mehr schlafen deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht ich mache heute dieses halten
zieht video wo ich euch einfach mal so
ein bisschen informieren was bei mir zu
die letzten tage ging was so großes mit
denen mit den teilen mit denen mit
meinen komponenten einfach mal
abgestimmt was so los ist mit den
komponenten was jetzt genau mit dem
kompressor war was mit dem mit dem mit
meinem neuen pc jetzt irgendwie ist
unser ein paar andere dinge wollte ich
einfach mal kurz sagen dass selbst los
ist und das habe ich halt jetzt hiermit
getan
ich weiß nicht was ich sonst noch sagen
soll ein herrliches video glaube ich
auch in zwei minuten packen können aber
ich rede hier immer gern ein bisschen
und damit würde ich eigentlich auch
schon sagen was ist das für diese runde
heiden sieg ich wollte dieses video halt
wirklich nur nutzen um einfach mal kurz
zu reden
um kurz zu sagen ja ich hab's
hingekriegt mit meinem kompressor das zu
einfach noch gekauft hat und ich habe
jetzt endlich auch mal neue pc
angeschlossen
das heißt freunde es ist flüssig was auf
jeden fall richtig cool und
dementsprechend freut euch auf weitere
videos auf einem kanal ich hoffe ihr
freut euch und morgen geht es dann ganz
normal weiter mit irgend einem anderen
video und übermorgen dann wieder eine
folge minecraft und dann würde ich sagen
ich jetzt auf jeden fall erstmal
schlafen und ich wünsche euch eine folge
gute nacht
tag oder morgen oder wenn auch dieses
video schaut und